we end each podcast I let you ask me one
question it's my least favorite part of
this cuz I never know if people ask but
anything that you'd like to ask where do
you think what do you think the ice
implications of Wall Street are cuz I
know you've submitted a letter to the
SEC regarding the ETF's do you agree
yeah I approach so I I do agree right I
think that there's two separate pieces
here right one is I truly believe that
there's a lot of people who are
interested they're intrigued yeah
and they don't have the technical
competence or the intellectual curiosity
to go figure out or the time yeah you
know how do I figure out what is Bitcoin
what are the risks associated what is
the potential benefit and how do i
purchase hold securely etc all they know
is this Bitcoin things interesting
people are talking about it they keep
getting stolen
I'm just go about my day yeah I think
when you get an etf for these retail
products etc right there's uh there's a
line to thread there between you're
giving access to a class of investors or
you know a subset of investors that
probably probably would never go to
coinbase right and go try to buy it
because they want to buy it through
their financial advisor yeah they just
want they they want somebody to yell out
when something goes wrong right and so I
think that you know for those people
this is good because it will give them
some exposure even though it's not the
best exposure at the same time the
financial engineering that comes in is
quite scary right and so I think that
one thing that I don't have an answer to
but I keep thinking through is what is
the trade-off right how that the
positive effect of the news right for
this base of retail investors who
frankly it's a pretty big aggregate
number of investors that have a lot of
money yes and so there will be an inflow
of capital once these things actually
you know come online and are and are
operational but is does that actually
outweigh the you know you the 10,000
pound gorilla of Wall Street now having
the ability to go do their you know do
what they do okay and you know there's
an element of is this almost a Trojan
horse right you know you get in the into
the fort to attack by saying hey we're
gonna give access to these retail
investors everyone's cheering in to your
point they don't see you know kind of
what's happening
in the background I don't know right and
so frankly I probably haven't been
around long enough in the kind of
traditional financial world to really
understand how to measure that that you
know kind of pro and con impact but i
think it's one of the most fascinating
things because you you move from you
know bitcoin four or five years ago was
in you know billions tens of billions of
you know market cap or circulation yes
now we're moving into institutions that
that's on their balance sheet right and
now all of a sudden you're playing with
you know an institution that three years
ago or four years ago could have just
bought the entire supply of bitcoin it's
so you know you're one of my partner's
always talks about going straight from
high school to the pros like bitcoin
just went straight from high school to
the pros and are we ready right i don't
know yet and i think that's gonna be one
of the most fascinating things to watch
yeah great great points great